y seguimos precisamente en italia en la
revista de prensa de directo américa ya
me acompaña en el estudio rosa pérez
rosa condena de 13 años de prisión al ex
alcalde italiano de richter compartamos
ahora los titulares desde guardián
mediapart y también la república en
italia buenos días exactamente nos hemos
querido fijar en la condena que se dio a
conocer ayer a domenico lucano también
conocido como mimo lucano que fue este
alcalde entre 2004 y 2018 que optó por
una forma de abordar la política
migratoria muy distinta a la de la unión
europea en general que es más bien
security securitaria y militarizada pues
él optó por compaginar no las
necesidades de su política municipal con
el hecho de proporcionar proporcionar
derecho a la educación a la vivienda y
al trabajo a los recién llegados al país
y entonces pues a raíz de esta condena
vemos como lo tratan distintos medios
comenzamos precisamente de rosa por the
gardian titula alcalde italiano prófugo
pero refugiados perdón sentenciado a 13
por cómplice de inmigración ilegal eso
es the gardian pues señala precisamente
esto como era reconocido
internacionalmente por distintas
instituciones y figuras como el propio
papa de roma por esta como comentábamos
esta forma de abordar la política
migratoria completamente opuesta a la de
la unión europea también destaca sus
declaraciones al conocer la sentencia
que fueron que no se lo podía creer
porque esta sentencia condenatoria de 13
años y 2 meses es el doble de lo que
pedía la fiscalía y bueno también
destaca que va a recurrir la íbamos a ir
siguiendo este proceso así es rosa
seguimos con mediapart mismo lucano como
ya lo dijimos exalcalde rh condenado a
13 años de prisión así titula exacto
pues en la misma línea mediapart este
medio
independiente francés también destaca
que es una prueba más ya de la
criminalización no sólo de la migración
clandestina sino también de la
solidaridad de las personas de los
ciudadanos europeos también con las
personas migrantes y por otro lado
también destaca como la extrema derecha
de salvini en italia y pues alrededor de
europa a los distintos movimientos están
celebrando esta condena vamos ahora por
último a la república en italia titulé
al alcalde que quiso ser humano en una
tierra donde todo se desmorona eso es
este periódico italiano en este artículo
es muy duro y muy crítico contra la
propia justicia italiana dice pues que
básicamente éste era de una figura que
confrontaba el status quo europeo y
también italiano en estas iniciativas
pues para promover los derechos básicos
a las personas migrantes que han llegado
a italia de forma clandestina y es que
recuerda que calabria la región donde se
encontraba esta municipalidad de riacho
pues pierde de ella emigran hasta 15 mil
ciudadanos al año por lo tanto esta
política también era una forma de
alentar la repoblación de esta zona y
finalmente bueno pues acaba con una
constatación bastante severa y es que la
justicia italiana dice ha dedicado más
esfuerzos en investigar a criminalizar
al ex-alcalde que no a ciertos miembros
de la mafia calabresa seguimos hablando
de la justicia italiana y también de
españa rosa vamos hasta el país el
supremo reclama italia medidas que
garanticen que carles puigdemont no
esquiva de nuevo a la justicia eso es
seguimos en italia en la isla de cerdeña
donde recordemos que precisamente hace
una semana el ex presidente catalán
carles puigdemont fue detenido por la
policía
italiana y también fue liberado debemos
de recordar unas horas después pero el
caso es que puigdemont tiene que ir a
declarar el próximo lunes 4 de octubre y
según la justicia italiana pues no
pasaría nada si no fuera a declarar se
archivaría al caso pero el expresidente
aseguró que iría ahora mismo se
encuentra en bruselas de nuevo pero
precisamente la justicia española
concretamente el juez de arena que es el
que ha llevado todo el juicio que se
conoce como la causa del proceso contra
los ex líderes independentistas pues ha
solicitado a la justicia italiana que a
raíz de esta nueva comparecencia de
puigdemont se aseguren los mexicanos
para que usted pueda someterse a la
justicia española y cerramos o rosa
repasando los cuatro años el referendo
de independencia de cataluña del primero
de octubre en 1.017 con el medio catalán
a diario el psoe raúl recordemos que eso
en 2017 seguimos con españa y la
cuestión catalana y es que el diario 'la
diaria hará que es este medio catalán
pues lo enfoca desde distintos puntos de
vista tiene aquí cuatro años de lectura
cuatro años del 1 de octubre y dice que
daiana les quedarían en 2017 que decían
en 2017 los partidos independentistas y
que dicen ahora y por otro lado que el
gobierno actual de esquerra republicana
quiere mantener vivo este espíritu del
del 1 de octubre de ese referendo que
recordemos no fue pactado por el estado
por con el estado por lo tanto no fue
reconocido como vinculante y dice que
ahora pues los distintos partidos
independentistas pues ya no lo reconocen
tanto como vinculante sino que pues el
que está al frente del gobierno catalán
intenta pactar con el gobierno español
eso sí para algún día celebrar un
referéndum pues que esté reconocido por
todo el país vamos a ver qué pasa con
esta cuestión de cataluña que además
data de muchos años atrás muchísimas
gracias rosa nos vemos el lunes con más
titulares de la prensa vamos ahora con